[Applause]
okay we got a lot of shutter get the boy
to be in a lot of show
[Applause]
give yourselves a hand for getting
through a hundred days of Donald Trump
right a hundred days at Trump it's like
Lent if we all gave up reality yeah
they're big on this hundred day mark
some people of course are disappointed
at his lack of accomplishment a lot of
mere Putin all that work for nothing
but you know who who thinks Trump is
doing a great job
a reporter asked him to grade himself he
gave himself an a knock over with a
feather Donald Trump giving himself in
it and you can trust that grade because
he used to own a fake University
the White House this week put out a list
of his accomplishments and most of them
were not accomplishments like on the
list was partnering with the private
sector yeah that's what government does
not an accomplishment
got all my kids jobs not really
something one of them just said word for
word I'm quoting this women and space
exploration yeah Trump Trump knows about
women and space his wife lives 200 miles
away you know but it's so telling he
gave an interview today and he was very
revealing he said this is this is more
work than my previous life I thought it
would be easier he said that yeah no
nobody knew nobody knew that
presidenting would be so hard it looks
so
it looks so easy in the movies when
Morgan Freeman does it he does here's
what he said he doesn't like he's
isolated he misses driving and when you
say stuff people check to see if it's
true
whiny little [ __ ]
but they just seem to be a pattern
emerging here after 100 days that we
could say first Donald Trump pulls [ __ ]
out of his ass and says so easy to fix
so easy then phase 2
nobody knew nobody knew it was hard and
then phase 3 we go back to what Obama
was doing trade with China go back to
that Isis go back to that policy the
Iran deal go back to that health care
NAFTA all the campaign only talked about
was not the worth you love a [ __ ]
disaster
now you know it happened this week he
talked to the Mexican president he
talked to the Canadian Prime Minister is
back on same thing happened when he
talked to the Chinese president suddenly
were on their side he's like The
Manchurian Candidate but you don't even
have to hypnotize him
[Applause]
this telling me is pretty you're all in
but but plainly we have this president
who knows nothing didn't know anything
about any of the issues not about the
basics and I mean the basics like how a
bill becomes a law how many branches a
government we have I mean he didn't know
what brexit was he didn't know who the
Kurds were he didn't know what the
nuclear triad it it's like the president
is a baby with a mobile over it he's
just learning about the gallery did this
week he bust the entire Senate did you
see this over to the White House to get
a briefing on North Korea the entire
Senate or as Sean Spicer said over a
million Senators
but you know this was mostly this super
top-secret briefing the entire Senate at
the beginning of the weekend mist
regimens who is all they could talk
about they trumpeted this was a very
serious stop all the Senators the
memorandum came out of the White House
said the Senate will be addressed by the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
the CIA the Secretary of Defense then
Rex Tillerson will speak because there's
a first time for everything and then the
president will talk about his ratings on
the apprentice and Ivanka's new line of
strappy sandals and the time he won the
electoral college cake will be served
and it will be the best cake a lot of
people are already saying it's the
greatest cake in the history of the
world mental illness is sad ladies and
gentlemen I think it if you need proof
of that
he unveiled the tax plan this week I
don't have time to go into the details
just suffice it to say the wealthiest
people in America are finally going to
be catching a break ladies a job and
isn't that awesome
if tax plan what a charitable word for
it it was one page with no math I'm not
kidding that's the tax plan that's not a
tax plan that's a resume for a manager
at Chuck E Cheese
[Applause]
they said it well it's ruff ruff I mean
there's ruff and then this is so rough
it needs a safe word and the secretary
and the Treasury secretary Steve
munchkins said he something like that I
can't pronounce any he said he wants
people's taxes to fit on the back of a
postcard and on the front of the
postcard an ad for 25% off on a bunka
strappy sandals they're really pushing
those sandals